la violencia étnica se reactivó en
kosovo Durante los últimos días pero
Cuáles son los orígenes de este nuevo
estallido tras los comicios locales el
conflicto en la provincia de kosovo
estalló en 1998 cuando la etnia albanesa
separatista se rebeló contra el gobierno
de Serbia que respondió con una brutal
represión dejando más de 10.000 muertos
y más de un millón de personas sin hogar
la mayoría albano kosovares no fue hasta
2008 cuando kosovo declaró su
independencia de Serbia pero Belgrado se
niega a reconocer la autonomía del
estado de kosovo pese a no tener control
formal allí si bien el territorio de
kosovo tiene un 90% de población al
panocoso bar La mayoría étnica
servocosovar del norte de kosovo que
intentó recientemente boicotear las
elecciones municipales generando
enfrentamientos con la policía tampoco
acepta la independencia y consideraba el
grado como su capital en 1999 la otan
intervino en el conflicto desde entonces
tiene más de 3000 soldados de las
fuerzas de mantenimiento para la paz
desplegadas en persona y cualquier
intervención militar de Serbia en kosovo
significaría un enfrentamiento con las
fuerzas de paz de la otan
esto
también es el resultado de la pasividad
de la comunidad internacional por un
lado en los meses anteriores habíamos
incrementado la presencia diplomática y
los esfuerzos para hacer algunos
progresos en relación con las
conversaciones de Bruselas pero el
problema clave aquí es el abandono de la
escalada la situación sobre el terreno Y
la acumulación de nuevos problemas como
resultado de las acciones de pristina
hacia la comunidad local ahora tenemos
una situación extremadamente tensa que
requiere una serie a presión por parte
de la comunidad internacional
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea median
en la negociación para la normalización
de relaciones sin lograr un acuerdo
final Y es que tanto Cristina como
Belgrado están dirigidos por líderes
nacionalistas reacios a compromiso
condición obligatoria si quieren avanzar
hacia la membresía de la Unión Europea